[Musique]
abidal vous répondez à londres pour leur
donner mon accord pour le congrès
j'insisterai du 18 au 21 vous maintenez
une place sur le premier avion de 18
trouvait le courrier n'a pas à faire
à
un super 1600 le journal denis à stagno
les pervenches plus cher que les
parcmètres rentrée
[Applaudissements]
tu vois ça comme ça
je
j'ai fait cette langue
il est fantastique ton père
tu te rends compte ça fait six heures
qu'il opère
[Musique]
c'était extraordinaire j'ai bien cru que
la terre que manet a été réparé à temps
plein en plastique formidable vraiment
formidable
déjà avec moi non je vais te dire les
cochons la vieille dame en bureaux
s'attend lui son disque d'or et bien
mystérieux
c'est pas facile à dieu
alors je t'écoute
je déteste moucharde c'est pas mon
habitude j'ai offs
bon bref act up et les précautions
oratoires jeudi c'est à cause de signes
de vie ouais de sylvie
depuis qu'elle est rentrée elle met
pratiquement plus les pieds à la fin
comme je sais par une copine à elle
astral à elle va bousiller une année
d'études je voulais en parler
ouais j'en ai parlé à envoyer sur les
roses et sec fous moi la paix
qu'elle reste tous les soirs à maison
pour attraper peut-être
moi je crois autre chose
bon je vous écoute mon cher watson je
pense qu'elle voit un type de la journée
qu'elle reste au soir la maison parce
que le type en question travaille la
nuit je sais pas
tout ça date d'il ya cinq semaines quand
maman est partie à new york est un type
qui a fait livrer des fleuves qui
explique
mystère
j'ai pas détective privé et puis la
filature très peu ton ça m'emmerde
savoir raconter tout ça si elle sait que
j'en ai parlé elle sera furieuse chacun
est libre de faire ce qu'il veut je vois
ce soit ouais comment tu me vois
pourquoi tu verra bien salut voila
souffre et la machine
ça c'est la part de maman ouvre d'abord
le bien et puis demi après le canal web
oui enfin comme cela que coûte
j'étais seul talent à dire attends
attends attends
malgr é
sur un canot pourrais-tu les opérations
au service les coûts tout ça c'est trois
points seule une partie quand même je
voulais tout mais non je dis tu vas
travailler le force combien de force
manuel tu dois t'en rappelé toi parce
qu'à mels a tué un chronomètre à la
place du coeur c'est ici mon mieux je me
demande comment fait affable moi
j'aurais l'impression de vivre avec un
horaire de chemin de fer comme on rigole
bien
bien fait oui sylvie sait jusqu'où à
bonhomme sans doute oui j'aime pas ça
j'ai le défi je ne vends pas jaloux je
pars avec elle pas d'une année c'est
tout n'empêche que le jour où il
arrivera avec un grand dadais en te
disant voilà c'est lui je lève tu feras
une drôle de tête
c'est un grand dadais oui mais même si
c'est un type bien tu rajoutes ne voit
ça d'ici mon nom mais messi messi c'est
classique
moi même quand ta soeur a pris un amant
j'ai fait en attraper une jaunisse
elle est une toute petite mercy
bon je commence
les reins
ce porte quittera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du besoin
entrée
[Musique]
j'ai lu le minesup bord
je lise oui j'avais tout à l'heure aux
s'y trouve pas c'est toi qui l'a choisi
oui tu aimes pas
dis moi ça me
tu n'as pas sérieusement l'intention
d'abandonner des études marion la preuve
pourquoi tu me demande ça la position
lucide et faire autre chose de me le
dirait on sait déjà tout dit dans cette
maison oui pourquoi
toi on te raconter des histoires 1
qui a dit ça pourquoi tu sais je
t'écoute c'est sûr que j'en dors mais de
quoi semaines ce petit qu on fait quoi m
pêche mais pas dans un état pareil
pourquoi tu es fier d'être un espion
mais pas celle de l'espagne je suis
majeur avec ciné c'est un garçon un
garçon non c'est un homme lequel 34 ans
c'est à cause de lui que tu veux mener
des études tout de suite les grands mots
pièce j'ai besoin d'avoir quelqu'un dans
ma vie non c'est plus 15 ans est-ce que
je supprime de quelque chose je suis là
alors je suis poli et aimable
c'est l'idée que tu m'aies cacher
quelque chose mais cool papa pour la
première fois de ma vie j'aime j'aime
complètement
il m'arrive une chose merveilleuse et
j'ai pas envie d'en parler tu peux
comprendre ça n'aurait absolument rien à
vous dire c'est pas quelqu'un de notre
milieu qui n'a rien d'un universitaire
ou d'un intellectuel d'ailleurs il n'a
pas envie de vous connaître
il me prend comme je suis pour ce que je
suis que je viens de tel ou tel milieu
là ni faire c'est moi qui l'intéressent
il s'appelle c'est un prix
il fait quoi des affaires il a de
l'argent c'est ça que tu veux savoir
quelle affaire
bon moi
on fait la paix
souviens de ce que tu m'as dit que tu
m'as offert ce tableau c'est pour mes 18
ans tu m'as dit maintenant tu joues ta
vie ta mère à moi on sera toujours là
pour te des sites en a besoin mais cet
avis
bonsoir
[Musique]
ja ja high tech est
allô allô michel bonjour mon amour oui
comment à new york
j'ai beau ça va bien les harfangs bruit
les enfants aussi et est une adaptation
et compréhensifs les producteurs 1 je
t'appelle cette nuit je dois m'asseoir
pour mineurs d'aujourd'hui
ta mère me manque
à cause de cette histoire me sylvie non
je disais ça parce que encore tu pouvais
faire l'aller retour dans la journée un
haut niveau du club te laisses ta mère
tranquille avec cette histoire de bien
j'ai déjà suffisamment difficultés avec
ses producteurs ses auteurs américains
c'est pas la peine de rajouter à sous
supplémentaires
quant à sylvie je règle ça à ma guise
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu vas faire rien et toi
non plus donc si tu le prends comme ça
excuse moi mon dieu c'est lui j'ai
essayé de parler à ta c'est d'essayer de
comprendre ce que la subit à ce qu'elle
était majeure
je crois vous avoir inculqué une autre
idée de la franchise
tu veux que j'essaie de se voir qu'ils
n'en n'ont surtout pas non elle est
majeure alors qu'elle est une sa
majorité
c'est lui c'est tombé oui j'ai tombé par
terre imagine
tu tombé par terre
tu n'arrives pas qu on donne des coups
quand même
je bouge pas
à temps
ces machins
tu n'es pas le faire comme ça j'ai tombé
papa merci
[Musique]
m
il faut une fourche est maintenant bien
difficile mon vieux l'archet leur barre
d'abord je veux vous dire que cette
démarche me déplaît profondément parce
que je n'ai pas l'habitude de faire
appel à des détectives privés et il ya
des choses qu'on ne peut pas faire soi
même monsieur robert je veux savoir
l'emploi du temps exact de jeunes femmes
je souhaiterais vous mener cette enquête
comme je le désire
je vais vous dire où cette jeune femme
sera demain je veux ou l'a suivi à
partir de ce moment là je vous savez à
qui elle voit probablement un homme
toujours le même jeu savoie qui est 7e
et ce qu'il fait bien
vous m'avez apporté une photo de cette
jeune femme évidemment bien son nom son
adresse
vous n'avez pas besoin de les connaître
c'est l'homme qui m'intéresse c'est moi
qui parlais contact avec vous tous les
soirs à 21h je téléphonais ici mes
clients sont généralement plus
coopératif monsieur lombard
c'est à prendre ou à laisser ans je
prends je prends et combien de temps
vous voulez vous que je suive cette
personne monsieur lombard une semaine je
veux savoir qui est cet homme d'une
manière détaillée comment il vit de quoi
et où vous saurez tout ça monsieur
remords
bien la photo monsieur bah ça demain à
13 heures boulevard malesherbes au
numéro 99 c'était pas t d ce moment là
que je veux savoir ce qu'il fait bien je
vous raconte pas non non non mais ce que
je remets le chemin
l'amygdale vous annulé ma présence au
congrès dont la semaine prochaine ou
leap je ne peux pas bouger de paille
je suis à l'hôpital tout sur les mastics
temps de trempage 2008 monsieur j'ai
bien de l'équipe et la ville à feu
voilà
comment ça va tout perdu
[Applaudissements]
sans fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
là
m
[Applaudissements]
on
oh et
[Musique]
oh
bah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui allô monsieur lombard vient de
regoûter
elle l'a quitté le boulevard malesherbes
à 14 heures elle a pris le bus elle est
entrée au 10 bis champs elysées c'est
une galerie un passage et elle a pris
l'ascenseur sûrement pour rencontrer
quelqu'un dans les étages
d'ailleurs sorti à 19h20 bon j'ai suivi
cette jeune femme jusqu'au métro
franklin roosevelt et puis je suis
rentré chez moi à attendre votre coup de
fil oui je saurai demain chez qui elle
est allée
[Musique]
une partie non pas ce soir avait un
enfant de toi ya quelque chose qui
cloche
qu'est ce qui ne va pas je me dégoûte un
peu
ah bon pourquoi ça je fais celui-ci lui
je vis tu veux dire chili s'était
amourachée d'un type 2 mais vous savez
qui c'est elle veut rien dire
enfin paul youth et elle est majeure
jusqu'à maintenant tout allait bien chez
moi j'ai l'impression que le ver est
dans le fruit
de quoi ils seraient tous même temps tu
t'aperçois que ta fille n'a plus 15 ans
tu vas arrêter cette histoire tout de
suite je ne saurais pas enfin bon dieu
laisse la vivre alors qu'elle dise
quelque chose je sais comment tu te
comportes comme un mari jaloux je veux
personne surtout pas des têtes perec va
ta fille et foutent en l'air une année
d'études à cause d'un homme ça te
plairait de la voir venir marquer le
coup cette abuserait savoie quelques
mots sans arrêt tout ce qu'elle m'a
raconté soit à table
cela après midi à la fac je savais
parfaitement qu'elle avait passé cinq
heures dans les bras de ce type a pas de
jalousie pas vu ma fille pour qu'elle en
arrive là
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon comme
nouvelle à t'annoncer mon père c'est
tout quoi arrêtes tu me fais mal
qu'est ce qu'il sait répond il sait que
j'aime un [ __ ] qui est en train de me
casser le poignet tu le dit mon nom j'ai
parlé seulement deux mois deux mois deux
mois
salou
souvent je me demande pourquoi je suis
folle de toi folle d'une sorte de fauves
dont je sait presque rien
parfois tu me fais peur
c'est vrai qu'avant de te connaître je
savais pas ce que c'était que de faire
l'amour ça suffit pas à expliquer
pourquoi je reste un jour peut-être
c'est à dire et tout c'est à dire et
tout depuis le début n'est plus le jour
dit garçon j'ai compris que j'étais pas
comme les autres qui a peur moi quelque
chose de différent
c'est tout à l'heure quand je parle de
ton père
ce cher
sur la butte massacrés
je serais parti
comme ça c'est plus fort que moi
le couple a quitté les champs elysées
vers 15h entre 15 et 16 heures maison de
couture ensuite exposition au grand
palais puis cinéma bon film retour aux
champs elysées à 19 heures la jeune
femme repart à 19h30
ensuite je continue mon enquête lui
s'appelle boris valberg 10 bis champs
elysées passe toutes ses soirées dans
une discothèque à la mode le nashville
rue de ponthieu près du rond point
il en est vraisemblablement le gérant ou
le propriétaire
la jeune femme en question semble très
éprise de cet homme qui la couvre de
cadeaux monsieur longueur une chose
cependant m'intrigue qui est vraiment
boris valberg
[Musique]
ça compte pour toi la famille ça
comptait oui beaucoup
tu viens de m'apercevoir que ça peut
plus rien dit j'ai fait un rêve cette
nuit enfin un cauchemar j'ai rêvé que
j'étais dans une forêt très sombre et il
y avait des gens qui voulait m'empêcher
de rejoindre j'avais une arme à la main
j'ai commencé à tirer je dirais surtout
le monde
je dirais tout le temps tout le temps
j'étais plein de sons tout devenait
rouge autour de moi je me suis réveillé
en alms
je voulais que tu sois là
c'est vrai ce que tu me racontes oui
pourquoi parce que j'ai tué quelqu'un
quand j'étais plus jeune
un merci noyées quand j'étais môme
savait pas nager
par là qu'elle est allée au bord d'un
lac lequel a marché en temps elle est
entrée dans l'eau avancez jusqu'à ce
qu'elle perde pied qu'elle coule ça
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit pourquoi elle a
fait ça
le salon la localité de file c'était son
ami de mon père
avec l âge présent
je suis monté dans un grenier je savais
qu'elle ait des armes à la résistance
j'ai pris un fusil
j'ai mis une balle dans le canon
je suis allé dans un bois près d'une
route qui l'emprunté chaque jour là j'ai
attendu quand il est apparu
je les lisais en temps
longtemps
je voyais grossir dans la ligne de mire
quand il a été à dix mètres de moi j'ai
appuyé sur la gâchette cartouches
étaient trop vieilli le couple pas
partie mais quelle que soit partie ou
non
ce jour là j'avais tué un homme
et depuis il à vis des autres a plus
jamais eu d'importance pour moi jamais
jusqu'à maintenant
peut-être
peut-être seulement
laisse moi un peu de peinture
toute la vie
[Musique]
voilà c'est probablement décoiffer les
os cassés moi c'est tout à leur capital
seb
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans un tiroir
de son bureau à gauche il ya une
bouteille
moi je vous appelez lombard le terrain
voilà pourquoi je tombais trop gros
morceau pour moi trop dangereux je
dirais pour eux
entre donc vous saviez qu'il était son
amant c'est pour ça que vous êtes
engagés
il salue d'autres finissent pas alors
votre fille mal parti c'est qui
passer mon magnéto là
en dessous boris valberg né le 15 mai
1946 à bordeaux par an marchand de vin
grosses fortunes est une brillante mais
se fait renvoyer de plusieurs
établissements scolaires motifs violence
sur les camarades exclus de l'armée pour
brutalité diverses et insoumission il
fréquente très tôt la pègre locale puis
monte à paris à 21 ans valberg est
inculpée et condamnée pour proxénétisme
deux ans en 76 une inculpation pour
meurtre dans la sphère piana au dernier
moment le principal témoin à charge et
abattu non lieu la police a néanmoins la
conviction que valberg était le
meurtrier de piana il ya deux ans il
investit 4 millions de francs lourd dans
le nashville
d'où viennent les fonds mystère l'an
dernier interpol fait des rapprochements
entre valberg et différents meurtres
commis en allemagne et en suisse en
france l'enquète ne mène à rien sauf à
cette conviction que valberg est un
tueur à gages qui opèrent en solo et
c'est pas déranger lui-même de voiliers
avec juste un avertissement oublie la
fille était enclenché qu'allez-vous
faire professeur raconter tout à votre
fille est expédié la loin d'ici très
vite
demain je sais pas trop tard trop tard
[Musique]
monsieur
c'est pas le bon
[Musique]
oui oui qui
install 2 fallen angel
[Musique]
et ce mot comme moi boris 50 bâton ça se
trouve pas comme ça c'était déjà laissé
un mois de plus serait assoupi à toi
petit lors c'est moi qui t'ai mis le
pied à l'étrier
il est fini le temps où je travaillais
pour toi et c'est précisément le
contraire maintenant alors le 12
pas un jour de plus à part la boîte tu
es à la barre ali salhi sa vue
[Musique]
m
exemple je veux vous cessiez de voir ma
fille immédiatement ce qu'on voit pas
très bien ce que vous êtes exactement
qui vous est une ex macro actuelle on
dit tant de choses c'est pas la peine de
vous en prendre à l'archet je l'aurais
su quand même marché
désolé nous lâcher cette gosse tâche et
je ne tiens pas monsieur terran qu'allez
vous imaginez sylvie fait ce qu'elle
veut de son plein gré elle est majeure
où semble-t-il
alors si ça ne colle pas avec ce que
vous souhaitez alors j'ai eu avec m
c'est votre problème pas mais qu'est ce
que vous voulez en fait vous voulez
l'amener dans un bordel sur le trottoir
vous dites des choses
bordel trottoirs macro tueur c'est très
grave professeur alors revenu sur terre
avait professé un professeur vous ayez
envie noël jamet et je les professeurs
relevez vos professeurs ce n'est pas une
position pour vous voulez retourner dans
la boîte
bonne idée découvrez les choses
soyez moderne professeur à moins que
vous ne préfériez la sortie des artistes
on va frapper
qu'est ce qui te prend des fous bientôt
le fait quoi et interpol fait des
rapprochements entre valberg et
différents meurtres commis en allemagne
en suisse en france l' enquête ne mène à
rien sauf à cette conviction que valberg
et un tueur à gages qui opèrent en solo
alors tu vas pas tout en lui un an 76
était 10 heures est une belle peau morte
maintenant tueur il a tout pour plaire
un l'a compris maintenant
alors demandez pas jointe à mai à la
mairie par nîmes par six au cours en
vigueur toi tu es de cours parfaitement
je sais que doris a fait de la prise et
on l'a dit pour proxénétisme c'est ce
qu'ont dit les flics
comment est ce qu'on dit les flics une
occupation pour meurtre ça tu fais pas
il a été condamné non alors tu te rends
compte de ce que tu dis je me rends
compte que tu réagis comme un flic tu me
rends compte que danton décidemment fait
quelque chose une fois pour qu'on vous m
importe quoi sur le dos il a une valeur
dans ce bar du fait qu'il fit ya 20 ans
mais le détective qui a recueilli des
renseignements s'est fait casser la
gueule seulement ces bienfaits des
hommes de main à son ami boris c3 pas tu
crois pas tout quoi va non seulement ses
mains police c'est monstrueux
et toi tu manges l'attend mais c'est
encore pire
mais pour qu'il porte pour juger comme
ça les autres pour dieu le pape s'est
levé ces textes trouvés dans la mer du
même mal de temps de pontifier sur ce
que vient le mal sur l'honnêteté la
droiture
j'ai envie de vivre de vivre cette
maison
françoise françoise vous sortez oui je
m'en vais me gène tic le chevallier sur
le clip année je passais couleurs mais
vous avez des rendez vous et les vôtres
mais vous allez tous vous en avez à 16
heures à 17 heures et à 18 heures deux
jeunes loups mais monsieur votre
serviette
les consultations s'il vous plaît
c'était pas bon c'est
car vite changé de décennie
tu vas me quitter
au contraire
je voudrais
je dois tirer un trait sur le passé si
tu veux bien
je veux bien
mais pour ça il faudrait que je parte
qu'est ce qui est de la france
lesage le frac si tu viens avec moi
t'es pas obligé d'apprendre qu'au dessus
cwi bourhis oui oui oui
et encore autre chose avant que tu
prends ta décision est vrai que tu
saches tout sûrement jusqu'au moindre
détail
de quoi tu as peur
je supporte parce que gmt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
et
[Musique]
ouais
à
il faut que je te parle
je craquais ce matin à l'hôpital
feu la première fois de ma vie mais
manabe c'est plus mon cerveau ne
fonctionnait plus parce que moi j'ai eu
deux mains horaires alors oui je re re
re armoires de l'hôpital j'ai
littéralement pris la fuite qu'est-il
arrivé exactement d'habitude
j'interviens sur la vie des le seul avis
deschamps j'ai physiquement médicalement
j'ai même j'ai même prolonger la vie ce
matin j'ai réalisé que oui
je réalisais que j'étais incapable
d'atterrir diana levine ma fille c'est
de ma faute si clichy levier fichu mais
qu'est ce que tu racontes
elle l'a elle a une liaison avec un
homme du milieu le proxénète un tueur il
faut le lui dire ce que je vais faire
elle n'aime pas elle sait vraiment qui
est certain c'est un fait maquiller
c'est pas possible ici et là des prêts
des coûts et un espèce de monde trouble
auprès duquel tout ce que je crois mais
rétrograde sans galère c'est de ma faute
total c'est comme quand on l'ouvré un
cancer plus nautique c'est trop tard
c'est foutu pas de ta faute si ta fille
s'est entichée d'un voyou messi
la prévenue taffard d'accord peu de
courage et a prévenu la police
la police est là comme moi que ce
qu'elle fasse la police sylvie est
majeur pour éliminer ce type où
l'accueil est frais il est vrai quelques
clubs prévu porte elle-même plaçe pas
moi
[Applaudissements]
ce que je vais faire j'ai cherché
partout tu étais pas l'hôpital
c'est oublier parti quoi ces leviers
partie elle a quitté la maison est sorti
non elle est partie avec une valise bien
voir
[Applaudissements]
elle a emporté son tableau aussi que tu
n'as pas retenu un dieu mais pourquoi tu
l'a pas retenu broggi excuses
désolé je sais pas je viens de rentrer
c'est de l'esclave est parti enfin si tu
m'expliques et où tu as raison
aux taxis elle a donné une adresse
je n'ai pas pu entendre elle était tout
près puisqu'elle m'a embrassé mais
l'auto est parti tout de suite merci
sylvie va revenir je la connais elle a
un bon poulet c'est merci de lui mais il
a pu aller dans un hôtel motel pourquoi
tel ou tel pourquoi pas directement chez
lui
d'après ce que tu m'as dit ce type sa
maison n'est qu'un départ comme ça chez
valberg fait tu vas prendre un allumé un
téléphone tu vas faire tous les hôtels
de choisy lisais je t'appelle dans une
heure ou deux tu bouges pas dit si tu
vas chez lui
[Musique]
c'est pas possible eh bien voilà
hier goldman professeur je peux être
fier de la maison pourquoi ne pas lui
demander vous même
goûter
encore une fois professeur ça ne
concerne qu elle quand accepterez vous
qu'elle soit majeure
dites les deux ans à venir
je donne à n'importe quoi
combien
cet argent que vous voulez
tuons macro maîtres chanteurs non
professionnels
j'ai pas besoin de l'argent
dites lui de revenir en supplie
décidément vous avez beaucoup changé
professeur à l'agonie suppliait je vous
en prie
l'après-midi professeur sortie des
artistes aujourd'hui vous la méritez
ah c'est toi tu te souviens pas tu
devais venir dîner chez moi j'ai attendu
j'ai téléphoné dix fois
à
stupeur
c'est lui
va-t-il y donne deux à l'hôtel
je comprends plus
et vive est autrement
je m'appelle
j'ai vécu pour rien rien j'ai travaillé
pour rien à vous tous toutes étaient
tous tenaient debout tout été
accueillants
aujourd'hui tout est cassé
je ne me chambrent
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ta soeur n'est toujours pas rentré ici
il faut prévenir sa mère qu'elle
revienne
d'accord j'ai appelé new york vous avez
votre fils au téléphone monsieur je lui
dit que vous étiez occupé bills à 6 mois
pour me passer à l'eau wii est un jeu
neuf où tu l attends tu à la maison on
vas tu ne bouge pas à ce soir
c'est fait mouche
tu es passé
si je suis seul mais j'ai pas envie
d'ouvrir tu as envie de te voir à temps
ça vaudra mieux pour tout le monde
boum laisse-moi vatan jetons prix
celui
c'est lui je t'aime
tu te mets toujours quoiqu'il advienne
je veux pas que tu souffres échec
tous les lois mais t'as pas loin de le
faire souffrir je veux pas que tu partes
je veux pas tout voir
c'est lui
je te connais
je te permets bas quand j'étais petit
j'étais malade je te paye et nuit et
joue encore la fierté des liens
je t'ai vu grandir j'ai vu des corps se
former je n'accepterai pas que tu partes
avec cet homme c'est lui il peut donner
la mort là bas oui c'est pas de l'amour
que tu en sors d'une opération de décès
prend pas un mirage de mots c'est pas ça
il dira plus tard sow patiente c'est
tout moi je t'aime plus
je te redonne de revenir avec moi
sylvie reviens je t'en supplie si tu
reviens pas la vie n'a plus de sens
[Musique]
il
allo
françois
excusez moi de vous féliciter je voulais
vous dire que je ne perde pas le matin
je vous appelez pour que vous preniez
des dispositions nécessaires d'ici même
si si si je mange à l'école s'ils font
ça c'est certain
[Musique]
non
qu'est ce que tu as
rien que ça je sais pas
je vais poser une question
si tutelle coliques et que je vais
arrêter de boire
enfin je veux dire si l'alcool pour toi
c'était comme une drogue
est-ce que tu ferais
pourquoi tu me demande ça répond je te
poser une question je crois que
moi je remplirai mon verre à ras bord
je le boira d'un seul coup je me dirais
que c'est le dernier
pas toi
exactement ce que je ferai
ils ont pourra pas se faire demain après
midi j'ai rendez vous ah non c'est le
dernier je te jure
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il tempère ou est il en ce moment à
l'hôpital sur nous
venise le tennis vous soyez gentils à
roger lachance de sylviane merci vous
aérer vous mettez les fleurs salue la
normale alors le bureau du professeur
terran s'il vous plaît allô allô
françoise michel terrain à l'appareil
bonjour oui oui oui je rappelle de paris
vient de rentrer vous passer mon mari
ah bon jeu je vous remercie de me le
dire françoise petit mois ci si elle
passe sa fin on sait jamais vous lui
dites que je suis rentré d'accord merci
au revoir françois
[Musique]
monsieur vous désirez je suivais dans
cette maison il ya longtemps que je les
ai achetées après la guerre à mettre ça
c'était mon père
ça fait quelque chose de revoir les
lieux où on est mais n'est ce pas on se
rappelle toujours tous plus grand j'ai
vu que bell oui merci vous bien
juste après la libération un soir en 44
mon père était si là et on parler de
l'avenir et ma soeur a dit je vais
travailler trice la toune 6 milliard
jeudi les voir
[Musique]
oh
en
[Musique]
bon d'accord je parle à une femme adulte
il pas ce qu'il lui plaît qui est
indépendante adi de mon propos tu peux
me dire comment tu peux y ait une suite
dans un palace c'est boris qui me la
fois parfait où tu feras ce qui te plaît
tu finiras dans un bordel harry aussi ça
chante seulement il mettra pas en danger
la vie de ton père rien mis en danger
ah bon il a cessé d'opérer si ça
t'intéresse
je vois pas en quoi je suis responsable
ben si tu ne vois pas tant pis pour toi
selon moi je tiens à ce que l'équilibré
reviennent dans cette maison écoute si
ton mari veut il s'agit pas de mon mari
s'agit d'un homme que j'aime depuis 25
ans et j'aiderai toutes mes forces
alors je te demande de revenir habiter à
la maison je vais partir en voyage avec
boris quand un dix jours
je viens d'ici là revient la maison
si tu ne fais pas pour lui il fait le
pour moi tu me demande pas où je pars de
garde
écoute civile lui que je suis ta mère
c'est simplement une femme qui viennent
demander à une autre femme de l'aider
c'est tout
alors
tu m'as temps
non j'ai une autre chose très importante
à faire merci
il y aura pas de scènes mais il aura
aucune scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
home à balma balle merci monsieur qu'est
ce que tu fais là tout seul ça faisait
si tu ne travailles pas non et qu'est ce
que tu fais quand tu travailles tu
georges et ckoi chirurgien je perdais ça
tu leur état les gens quand elles sont
parties du cerveau ou faire ma poupée
qu'est ce qu'elle a en rue des mois il
faut donner un coup de la jambe
dépêche toi tu ne vois pas quelle est la
très mal
pourquoi te fais ça non il a plu mais
maintenant elle va très bien toutefois à
la future s à la table des jeux m'avait
fait on va déjà merci merci de quoi
jean jean michel bichain jean claude
matheu raconter comment as-tu
poissonneuse thumy emmenait une fois une
fois où ça allait très mal entre nous
tu aurais pas fait ça quand même
celui-là tu sais j'ai un côté une petite
j'ai vu une poupée mal année qui me
monte comment il fallait faire pour
continuer à la fif
quand nous rentrerons il dit sera de
retour à la maison en attendant de
partir en voyage
l'homme aime dans dix jours oui
ça me laisse dix jours pour essayer
quelque chose pour tenter de la
convaincre se laissent du jour
genre je voudrais que tu recommences a
opéré demain de mieux bleus cela fait
plus peur mais je vais le ch mon père je
sais que tu viennes intérêt majeur
jamais pu faire alors il faut y aller
je
je suis là
je voudrais qu'ils soient revenues même
provisoire
je te mets une chaussée nous paraît
derrière c'est exactement ce que jal est
proposé
rien ne nous dit non à 8h15 comme
d'habitude je ne sors jamais le soir
comme d'habitude
oui merci
[Applaudissements]
alors longue et michel est rentré sylvie
aussi tout va bien très bien
je vais faire proposition s'il est
honnête souci est tout jeune et je vais
faire une partie
toutefois même si elle doit durer dix
jours une partie de championnat jusqu'à
une faq
mais
moi
ancien patron sur le sol
de là on m'a demandé de rentrer alors je
respecte les usages de la maison
enfin leur appartement oui dans sa
chambre il a décidé de travailler parce
qu'il travaille lui peut-être suffi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trop tard mais c'est de dormir je suis
pas encore remis du décalage horaire
à new york il est 3 heures de l'après
midi
pour un somnifère le léger tout à
l'heure à nous de molière ce soir échec
et mat en 5
le tronçon soit c'est moi qui gagne
échec et mat
[Applaudissements]
la somme a demandé par personne
arlette non non non personne pour sa
part est maurice
comme ça
et c'est ça
ouais
quatre jours
les blagues bien foutu le camp
au bout des gants
[Applaudissements]
et art non non non dartois
[Musique]
à